the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones Season eight teaser breakdown
video what I want to do today is address
some of the comments I'm still receiving
about the Crips a wonderful teaser HBO
released a few weeks ago before we get
started I do want to make a quick
announcement about the new giveaway that
I want to do I know there are a good bit
of you who still haven't read the books
since Game of Thrones is coming to an
end very soon I figured this would be a
good time to do this because it will
give someone the opportunity to get
caught up with the source material I
will be giving away the complete a Song
of Ice and Fire book collection so if
you are interested in this giveaway just
click on the link that is down below and
follow those instructions good luck
everyone now let's get started as I said
before what I want to do today is
address some of the comments I have been
receiving about the crypts of Winterfell
teaser HBO released a few weeks ago when
this new teaser came out it left many
people with a lot of unanswered
questions one of the questions has to do
with the new statues that are done in
the crypts of Winterfell in that video
we can see John Sansa and Arya as
they're looking at their very own
statues many fans have already said that
it could be foreshadowing the death of
John Sansa and Arya Stark that actually
does make some sense because we do know
the type of threat House Stark is about
to face
we know that the night king is heading
south and we know he is heading their
way not only that but we also know what
the night King and his army of the Dead
are capable of John songs and Arya could
definitely die by the end of next season
however just because we saw their
statues down in the crypts of Winterfell
does not mean they are destined to die
what I mean by that is this is not the
first time HBO has done something like
this and one of their teasers most of
you should remember one of their teasers
from season six this was when HBO
released their video about the Hall of
faces that is in the house of black and
white where Arya Stark did her training
with Jagan agar and
that Hall of faces teaser we see
something very similar to what we saw
when that [ __ ] so NFL teaser now you do
have to keep something in mind this
video came out right before season 6 was
released what we can see in that video
is a bunch of different characters faces
and the house of black and white we do
know that these are the faces from
characters that have already died that
Hall of faces teaser begins just like
the [ __ ] so NFL teaser in the Crips of
Winterfell teaser we can see Jon Snow as
he walks past Ned Stark statue then we
can see Sansa walk past lady Catelyn
statue when they do this we can also
hear a few different quotes from netten
Catelyn well almost the exact same thing
happens in the Hall of faces teaser we
begin to see the faces of old characters
that have died in earlier seasons as
they are showing their faces we begin to
hear some of their quotes from earlier
seasons as well now let's take a look
that way you know exactly what I mean by
this
hoorah come to my family all because I
couldn't love a motherless child
you are a stock the man who passes the
sentence should swing the sword
and when everybody as I'm losing this
woman so as you can see by those video
clips both of those teasers basically
started out the exact same way we saw
and heard some of those dead characters
speak now let's see how that teaser
comes to an end like I said earlier when
that crypts of Winterfell teaser came
out we could see John Sansa and Arya
looking at their own statues many fans
thought that this means those characters
will die next season but I don't think
that is necessarily true
that's because HBO did almost the exact
same thing for season 6 when they
release that Hall of faces teaser now
let's have a look the long night is
coming
and the dead come with it in that video
we can see John Sansa and Arya spaces in
the Hall of faces at the house of black
and white the interesting thing about
this one is we can see the face of
almost every main character from the
show they show Tyrion Daenerys Jaime
Sansa Arya and many many more characters
now as we all know none of those
characters died in season 6 although
that is basically what HBO was trying to
imply by showing their faces and the
house of black and white so what does
all of this tell us in my opinion just
because we see Jon songs and arias
statues and the crypts of Winterfell
teaser that does not mean they are
guaranteed to die next season just like
what the season 6 teaser HBO is hoping
to generate some excitement by having
all of us think these characters will
die also I don't know if any of you
noticed it or not but they even played
very similar music in both of those
teasers as well
listen very carefully to the music and
you might be able to notice it to
everyone every muscle
as I'm losing this woman show them how
to lose what they love everyone is mine
to torment
now there is one major difference in
these videos that I do want to mention
even though we saw all those main
characters faces in the house of black
and white
anyone with some common sense would have
known that all of those characters could
not have died during season six
Daenerys hadn't even made it to Westeros
yet and we knew that most of those
characters stories were nowhere near
finished but when it comes to the crypts
a wonderful teaser even though John
songs and arias statues might not mean
that they will die we do know their
stories are coming to an end one way or
another now the books are a completely
different story but their character arcs
are coming to an end in the television
show I have already made some videos
where I predicted which characters I
think live or die but since I'm talking
about John songs and Arya in this video
let me tell you what I think happens to
each of these characters next season
these three characters are a little
harder to predict than some of the
others because I can easily make a case
for why they could die or why they could
live now when it comes to characters
like Samwell Tarly Davos Seaworth
ginjury and many others I am confident
those characters will survive the show
then when it comes to characters like
Cersei Lannister beric Dondarrion
Joran Greyjoy and many others I am
confident that those characters will die
before the end of the show but then
there are some of the other characters
where I find myself constantly trying to
guess how their stories end when it
comes to Jon Snow I really think his
story can go either way since Jon Snow
has already died once I would like to
think that he will survive all the
battles to come but on the other hand I
could also see Jon getting killed before
he would ever have the chance of living
some kind of a normal life
based on some of the things Game of
Thrones has done in their previous
seasons I wouldn't be surprised if Jon
Snow did die before he had a chance to
find out who his parents actually are
just because I am really hoping that Jon
does find out the truth I could see him
getting killed off before he ever got
that closure now I know that it does
seem very unlikely that Jon would die
before he finds out because he is
already on his way to Winterfell and
bran is already there waiting for Jon to
show up but you know how these things
tend to play out if you remember back in
the first season Robb Stark was able to
capture Jaime Lannister and everyone
thought that he could trade Jamie to get
Ned released from the black cells but we
all know how that ended
then in season three we thought that
Arya Stark was finally going to be able
to reunite with her family but as soon
as she made it through the twins her
family was inside getting butchered then
during last season we think we're gonna
get all these amazing stark reunions but
it just ends up getting really awkward
and uncomfortable even Sansa and Arya
were on the verge of killing each other
so even though it seems like John will
show up and Winterfell and have all
these amazing reunions and find out all
that information like I said we know how
these things tend to play out for House
Stark obviously I hope something like
that does not happen but I am preparing
for the worst
when it comes to Arya Stark most of you
should already know what I would like to
happen I don't see Arya spending the
rest of her life at Winterfell she will
either go west of Westeros like she has
always dreamed or she could settle down
somewhere in the Stormlands with Gendry
that is after Gendry is legitimized and
given some land of his own that would
fulfill Robert Baratheon's wish from the
first season and that is joining the
houses of House Stark and house
Baratheon Robert has a son Ned has a
daughter they will join their houses but
I also tend to think that it might be
too happy of an ending for her character
Arya Stark may already be too far gone
for her character to have any type of
ending like that not to mention the
future of Arya Stark may have been
foreshadowed in the very first book a
game of Thrones they say that all the
best clues for how the story will end
can be found in that first book because
the author george RR martin initially
only intended on writing a trilogy at
first therefore he should have planted
most of his seeds in that book
well when John and Arya were stolen
Winterfell together Jon says something
to Arya that may have shed some light on
how her story does end in Arya Starks
very first chapter in the books Jon Snow
says this the longer you hide the
sterner the penance you'll be selling
all through the winter when the spring
thaw comes they will find your body with
a needle still locked tight between your
frozen fingers now you can interpret
this however you would like but I do
find it interesting that John does make
a reference to finding Arya Starks dead
body frozen in the snow if george RR
martin did truly hide the clues for how
these characters store
in the first book then what better place
to hide it than in these characters very
first chapters let me know what you
think about that one
now when it comes to Sansa Stark I would
like to think that she would have the
best chance of getting killed simply
because she doesn't know how to
physically defend herself at least Jon
Snow and Arya Stark know how to fight
but Sansa does not from what we have
seen
Sansa has never trained with the weapon
so when Winterfell gets surrounded by
the army of the Dead
you would think Songza may find herself
in some serious trouble if the castle
gets over and however as I have said in
some of my other videos I actually think
that Sansa will live and continue to
remain as the lady of Winterfell they
may have even been suggesting this and
that crypts the Winterfell teaser when
we see Sansa in that video we can see
that she is the one who walks past lady
Catelyn statue and as we all know lady
Catelyn was once the lady of Winterfell
just like song says today when I made my
breakdown video I also mentioned how
that teaser came to an end as we see
that cold air creeping into the crypts
of Winterfell
we can see Jon and Arya pull out their
weapons if you look very closely it does
appear to me as if Jon and Arya are
standing slightly in front of Sansa
almost as if they are protecting her
since the battle will happen at
Winterfell and songs is the lady of
Winterfell I imagine they will do
everything in their power to keep Sansa
as safe as they possibly can knowing she
cannot defend herself on her own but
anyways let me know what you think the
main thing I wanted to show you today is
the similarities between the season 6
teaser and the season 8 teaser as I said
before just because we see those new
statues down in the crypts of Winterfell
it does not necessarily mean that those
characters are meant to die this is not
the first time HBO has done something
like that also don't forget about that
new giveaway you can win the entire A
Song of Ice and Fire book collection
just click that link that is down below
I want to thank all of you for watching
the video the support lately has been
absolutely off the charts and I cannot
thank you all enough
I truly appreciate that I hope everyone
has a great day
I'll see you soon bye
you
[Music]
you